oh we know it is a wet and wild place
but it wasn't always that way way back
4.6 billion years ago when the solar
system was first forming the inner part
was bone-dry heat from the Sun vaporized
any ice that dared to wander near it
leaving the rocky stuff that would
become earth water free so how did water
get here for a while some scientists
thought water road here on icy dirt
bottles called comets but the chemical
signature of comment ice doesn't match
that of Earth's water so comments are
out Tally's asteroids to carry the load
wait
asteroids have water yep and they've got
water to earth it's possible how does
that happen well it's kind of a crazy
story here's what the solar system
looked like a couple million years after
it formed there was the Sun a planet
which we now called Jupiter and one that
we now call Saturn there was some rocky
asteroids between Jupiter and the Sun
and there was some watery ones between
Jupiter and Saturn and there was some
farther out with Neptune and Uranus
let's keep it simple
forget Neptune and Uranus for now let's
focus on Jupiter Saturn and the Astros
okay so about seventy thousand years
after Jupiter forms the gas disks
circling the Sun pulls the planet inward
throwing some rocky asteroids out of its
way a few thousand years later the Sun
pulls Saturn inward to but sudden starts
crowding Jupiter it gets all up in
Jupiter's space their close
gravitational dance flings them both to
the outer solar system in reaction a
bunch of icy asteroids shoot into the
inner solar system these water intruders
collide with the stuff that's already
there more and more collisions make
bigger and bigger rocks which become
planets until finally everything in the
inner solar system is exactly as we see
it today seems like an incredible story
it is but it may not be unique something
similar may have happened somewhere else
in the universe that means there could
be other wet-and-wild worlds like ours
out there maybe in galaxies far far away
or one much closer to home